est-ce que vous pensez quelquefois la
mort non
depuis que j'étais tout petit pourquoi
pas c'est notre compagne n'est-ce pas
qui nous critiquera jamais
j'étais une fois à Nice même où j'ai
fait on m'a fait rire un petit papier
quand on a reçu je ne sais pas combien
de milliers de milliers de jeunesse du
monde ça vous rappelez
alors j'étais là sur les monuments aux
morts vous savez non monsieur avec une
foule qui venait depuis l'avocat comme
ça comme ça jusqu'à Nice n'est pas sur
la route et alors là je lui je sais pas
quoi qu'est-ce que c'est lui parce que
c'était très court et c'était pas moi
qui l'avais écrit mais enfin j'ai
prononcé quelques mots j'ai eu le plus
grand succès il paraît je sais pas
comment ils ont entendu quand moi je
n'ai pas l'habitude de parler de mes
amis gros mais hier soir c'était
fantastique je vous regardais au milieu
de cette Salim immense vous étiez petit
presque perdu même au milieu c'est cool
est-ce que vous avez été quand même
impressionné
[Musique]
de cette espèce de sympathie amour ou je
sais pas où amitié qui étant déjà mes
portes
justement vous aimez beaucoup le mot
amour Pablo Picasso
je sais pas quel jour là tu lui avais
dit ça vous savez pour moi et après
l'amour n'est-ce pas vous aimez bien les
gens j'aime beaucoup les gens tout le
monde j'ai adoré patience je sais pas
qui se réveille j'aimerais me voir un
bouton de porte n'est-ce pas
en pot de chambre n'importe quoi
qu'est-ce que vous aimez la télévision
aussi pas tellement
j'ai commencé à jouer parce qu'il y
avait le mariage de la de la princesse
barberette et quelqu'un m'a prêté un
appareil alors j'ai vu le filet de la
princesse et j'ai continué après vous
savez ce qui serait formidable quand on
vous a devant les caméras de télévision
ce serait de vous laisser tout seul en
liberté vous seriez tellement capable de
faire des choses formidables pour les
téléspectateurs vous leur inventeriez
des choses
des fois des fois je trouve des choses
magnifiques la télévision que j'aime qui
m'intéresse mais la foi et c'est des
fois
je le dis mais parce que on est là tous
les deux tout seul ah non c'est pas
comme tout le monde m'écoute est-ce que
si vous deviez choisir vous-même
l'époque la peinture la toile qui
devrait vous survivre est-ce que quel
stress cette toile quel serait cette
période
c'est fait avec des intentions tellement
du moment de l'époque et l'État dans
lesquels et tout le monde et moi nous
nous trouvons que c'est très difficile
au moment de
[Musique]
garnitagement de beaucoup d'autres que
nous avons suivi n'est-ce pas mais en
France c'est comme ça
sont des mémoires qu'on s'écrit soi-même
des cahiers
vous êtes extraordinairement jeune Pablo
Picasso est-ce que vous pensez
quelquefois
et peut-être que c'est une un jeune
est-ce que vous pensez quelquefois la
mort non
[Musique]
c'est notre compagne n'est-ce pas qui
nous quittera jamais ça c'est la seule
femme
[Musique]